[Music]
assalamu alaikum brothers and sisters
today
we're gonna be talking about history
[Music]
oh bro i can't i can't do this
um a lot of you guys have addressed the
point that brother angel
is moving around too much and we're here
thinking he wasn't moving around enough
so
yeah gave him the full 360.
mm-hmm yeah bismuth guys and girls
welcome back to the t3m
podcast rami why don't you tell us what
we're talking about today
today we're talking about
the history of islam
islamic historicity
and why is it important to know the
history of islam
why is it important well you know as
they say history is the greatest teacher
history is the greatest teacher and if
you look at today's society
we we see how we've fallen that's why
allah tells us mostly about moses
and the children of israel peace be upon
him
because they had a messenger and a
nation we have a messenger in the nation
we could see where they fought you know
where they were where they faulted where
they went
astray and where they messed up so
these are key key pieces we must keep
and these key evidences these key
lessons we must take into consideration
to avoid falling but what happened we
fell
inevitably so it's important to know why
we fell where it come from why was why
was so
strong in the beginning with the
prophetic and the sahabah
and where we lost it so
do you guys know the when the prophet i
sent him first revealed revelation
or one sorry when he first received
revelation i believe he was
23.
23 is the number of years he received
revelation
over from makkah to medina
right how old was he tell us he was 40
years old
no yeah most prophets received
prophethood at 40 years old
actually that's what i hear but um and
it's amazing it's
how they chose 40 also another side note
every single prophet was a shepherd as
far as i know every single prophet was a
shepherd
because they had to know how to lead the
animals and be a leader
and lead an entire group of people who
don't even have morality or
proper intellect compared to humans yeah
so they have to learn how to lead these
animals
to learn how to lead the humans in the
long run and it takes a lot of patience
and so on and so forth
but that aside do you know where the
prosthetic setup first received
do revelation know the story the cave
and
this is about the others honestly man
i'm kind of glad that
and i'm not speaking on behalf of me and
on hell i'ma just go based on me
i'm glad that i don't know as much about
islamic history
and the upbringing and uprising as much
as you because i'm looking forward just
like the viewers
of learning a lot in this talk right man
it's the lecture now bismillah
all right so the promise of allah
a monogamous marriage and he actually
worked for one of her businesses or for
her business
and he was the top performer you know of
course
high performers tend to be high
performers and everything so allah set
up and he was just
one of the best people he was already
known as the truthful and the
trustworthy
people would trust him with his
belongings they would trust him to be
truthful in all situations because
that's who he was sallallahu even before
prophethood
so he like ibrahim alaihissalam
he would look at the people you know
worshipping paganism
worshiping or sorry engaging paganism
worshiping statues and idols and all of
this stuff
and he's like that doesn't make any
sense why are they doing that what are
they getting from it
so the prophet said he used to go up he
used to climb
and it was a long journey to climb up a
mountain and get in a cave
with and he'd have like his food and all
that stuff ready and he used to
do what you and angel do meditate he
used to meditate in a cave sallallahu
and he used to reflect and think you
know obviously there's more to this
life and everything than these statues
this paganism and they know who allah
was they
they they know who allah is they they
knew who he was back then they referred
to allah
but some of them saw these pagan or
sorry this these statues and idols as
beings that would intercede for them to
allah
obviously we know this is haram there's
no such thing so then allah sent the
angel gabriel
a saddam before i get to this point i
want to mention
now the process that i said he's at this
point he used to see a lot of dreams
like he used to see a dream that
something would happen
and then the next day it would happen
and this went on
for however long it went on for a while
and then when he was in the cave the
angel gabriel peace be upon him came
and he told him to read he said iqra and
he said i don't know i'm unlettered i
don't know how to read
and then the angel picked him up and he
squeezed him
tight to the point where the prophet
said said he thought he was going to die
and i'll get into that in a bit and then
he put him down he said ikra he said
read
and prosely said i don't know how to
read why you like man i don't know how
to read i can't do this man
and he picked him up again and he
squeezed him again to the point where he
felt like he was gonna die
and he put him down and he said read and
he said i don't know how to read and
then
and then he was picked up again a third
time and he was squeezed again to the
point where he thought he was going to
die and then he put him down
he said read he said iqran the prophet
said ikra
bismi rabbikar i think that's how it
goes but i may be wrong it says
read or recite in the name of your lord
the one who created man so once over
this entire beautiful
passage of the quran unfortunately i
don't have it memorized
and that's the first time process said i
received revelation
and then he obviously like anyone any
decent normal human being is going to be
like what the heck
just happened i have this memorized in
my heart and i was just squeezed to the
point where i felt like i was going to
die
so he's shaking he's trembling he's
scared he's cold you know when you go
through
something not shocking that's traumatic
you tend to shake and get cold right
that's what the procedure they said
about what happened to him so he ran
home to his wife
and he said zimmi looney zami looney
cover me cover me so she covered him
and he said what happened and she
reassured him that listen you are a
great man you take care of the orphans
you give in charity you care for the
people you're trustworthy and truthful
you've never done even a little bit of
wrong allah would not do you wrong
allah would not forsake you in this way
and then
she ended up taking him i believe to her
uncle or her cousin
who was actually very knowledgeable when
it comes to religion
and then they they told him they
narrated him what happened and he
basically informed him that he is the
prophet of allah
this this was the angel gabriel the
angel of revelation and he has come to
you when you are a prophet from god
and he told him i wish
or i hope to be alive because he was a
very old man he said i hope to be alive
when the people drive you out
and he said what my my people the people
who see me as
trustworthy and truthful and honest
they're gonna drive me out
and he said yes every single prophet
there was not a prophet that was sent
there was not a messenger that was sent
except he was boycotted and kicked out
by his people
and now the prophet saws he begins his
journey of giving dawa and stuff
but it wasn't that simple it wasn't that
easy that's often how we hear it but the
process
actually went through a i'll call it
an intercession stage what i'll call it
and not that somebody's interceding but
he's kind of going from one place to
another
and in this moment he goes through you
know a mix of emotions
and he was including in these emotions
including these emotions were actually
depression and worry and anxiety to a
point where he actually didn't want to
live anymore
this is something that i myself have
been through this is something that
unfortunately many people have been
through and it's just the point of i
don't want to live anymore
and faster than i said he actually
climbed to the top of mountains
with the intention or at least the
thought of jumping off
of killing himself because of what he
saw and he wasn't sure but every time he
got to the top he would see the angel
again
and he would go back down and then the
the when he saw
one time he saw the angel jibril gabriel
al-islam
into the sky and it's a beautiful
narration i won't go too deep into it
but he saw him in the sky
and again he was trembling and he went
back to hiding
for the second time they said cover me
cover me
and then he received the second
revelation which says oh you who was
covered
get up and go warn remind the people
don't sit down
and be scared get up and remind the
people and
sallallahu after that he got up and he
started preaching
very beautiful story he then went
to you know how we have like fire alarm
systems
or like um amber alerts and all that
nowadays
imagine back then like imagine i don't
know what it was but let's say they had
like a signaling system like a giant
bonfire when you see a giant
pit of smoke go up in a certain area
it's an emergency right
so i don't know what it was it's not a
bonfire maybe it is i'm not sure but
they had the signaling system whatever
it was
and he basically called all the people
to come gather and he said people if i
were to tell you there was an
army behind this mountain coming to
attack us would you believe me
and they said yes of course you've never
lied to us
and then he said okay okay good that was
just preparing them he said
now that you know when you admit that
you trust me in anything i say
he said i am a messenger from allah and
he started preaching to the people
he started preaching to the people but
what happened
what happens is what happened is always
what happens
every single time the elite the highest
of the society
they go and they say don't listen to
this guy he's crazy he's a lunatic he
doesn't know what he's saying he's a
liar he's a
soothsayer he's a magician he's all
types of things except for whatever
what he really is keep worshiping your
idols go back to what you're doing no
one believe in him and from these people
were
his uncle his own family his own
tribesmen
and this is when he came out publicly at
this point he had preached to a few
people in private
like abu bakr allah like
and they accepted islam but when he
preached to the people publicly it was a
different
it was it was a different um game now
right
you're no longer hurting sheep you're
dealing with people
who have power even power over him until
allah is
you know who is exalted is all strength
and might
but on this earth allah gave power to
these people
and they're coming and saying don't
don't listen to him he's crazy
and a few people accepted islam most
people didn't the muslims were very
persecuted at the time
and it was a very very very difficult
time for them
especially in the first
three to six years of islam i'd say
especially
before omar and hamza allah convert
because umar
if you guys know radial is a giant
he was huge people would say that like
he would be
moving in a crowd of people and people
would think he's on a camel
because of how tall he was but he was
just standing that's how big he was
and then you have hamza ready who is
literally
a hunter who would go on expeditions and
all of this stuff the uncle of the
prophet
and at this time neither of them were
muslim so
there's one story and this this will
just kind of
help you understand how persecuted the
prophet was even by his own
tribesmen his own people so
abu jahl angel likes to call everybody
nowadays my favorite word now
this man calls me last night and he's
like yo what does jio mean
and i tell them what it means and how it
originated from the term jahilia
and this wasn't even 24 hours ago bro
and since then i've heard him say it
like
10-15 times
this guy was named by by the muslims he
was named
the father of ignorance that's what he
was called because he was an ignorant
individual he was a dumb individual
you know those you know those freaking
those soy boys who you know
they don't know how to engage with their
feminine side or anything they don't
know how to deal with the issues of life
and they're just so
emasculated that when anything goes
wrong they
just want to be vulgar apparently this
man was having a bad day
and he took out on the prosthetic and he
was cursing him in horrible ways and he
was doing horrible things to him
and then when hamza who was a hunter
came back from an expedition
he was talking to people chatting with
them you know chatting it up
everything's good like usual and then
some lady comes in like what the heck is
wrong with you
you're gonna sit here and chat it up and
be happy when your nephew
was just abused by that man and he's
like wait what are you talking about
and then once he was informed that smile
turned into an angry angry frown
and he picked up his bow he dropped all
his stuff he picked up his bow he walked
up to abu jahl
and he looked him in the eye and he just
just knocked him on the head with the
bow and he starts gushing out blood
and he's like what did he do to my
nephew what did you do
and he's like all of this because he's a
muslim and then he's like i'm a muslim
what are you gonna do about it
and hamza he's ready literally everyone
gets up from the table and they're all
ready to fight him and he's ready to
fight
he's ready to throw hands and he's like
because the thing is like nobody wants
to fight hamza the first one to go
adam is getting done he's done and they
all know that because hamza's he's just
a sick fighter
so they're all looking at him like are
we going to go are we going to go and
abu jahl is the one that stood up and
said
you know we don't want to cause problems
whatever eye for an eye to even now
forget about it and then hamza went home
he's like
i really just said i was a muslim and
he's like i don't want to go back and
publicly
you know take that back after the big
show i just put on
so he's like oh allah allah if islam is
true then make it easy in my heart
open my heart up to it and if it's not
then just let me die just let just take
my soul cause like i don't want to
retract my words
and when he woke up he found islam in
his heart and he went to the frost
and he said
sometimes they would say you instead of
muhammad they would say you are the
messenger of allah
so now they have hamza on board
alhamdulillah things start to pick up
for the prophet you know he has
he has protection from his uncles he has
things are going well he's preaching
things are still difficult muslims are
being
abused including a slave and other
slaves
amongst them who are being completely
abused by the non-muslim
masters this term master and slave was
abolished later and they replaced it but
for now it was still slave and master
and the first murder of islam i believe
was a woman
may allah be pleased with her who was
very
horrendously murdered i'll say i'm not
going to go into detail but horrendously
murdered
she was a slave woman i believe um
and so you could you could just imagine
you know how painful it is for the
prosthetic
to be preaching this and islam to be
completely peaceful they are they're not
allah did not instruct them to go to war
or anything at this point so he's
preaching to the people
hamza comes along and then the prophet
salallahu
he says oh allah give us one of the two
omars
now abu jahl his real name is umar omar
and the other um who is the one who
i've been talking about now he said give
us whichever you love more
bring him to us and allah answered his
dua
but not in the way that people would
expect it because allah moves very
subtly and allah as he says in the quran
is the best of planners
so listen to this beautiful story
he's sitting with you know abu jahl and
all these
all these ignoramuses and they're just
talking about you know muhammad this guy
had been preaching for six years and
like let's just like i'm so done with
him man
we can't get rid of him this that other
he's like you know what um
he's like you know what i'm gonna kill
him i'm just gonna go i'm gonna kill him
i'm gonna poke him and i'm gonna leave
it's done you guys have been crying
about it for this long i just want to
end it
so he gets up he picks up his sword he's
going to murder the prosthetist and lost
his intention
right and then one of the muslims sees
it and he's like
this doesn't look good so he goes up to
me he's like oh
where are you going he's like i'm going
to kill muhammad sallallahu alaihi
and he's like damn what do i do now and
this muslim is thinking thinking he's
like i have an idea
because omar's sister is actually
a muslim now with her husband they're
both muslim and they're actually in
secret practicing islam and learning
about the quran
so he's like why don't you go to your
own house and make sure none of them are
muslim
and keep track of them before you go
outside your home to the to muhammad saw
and he's like what are you talking about
and he told him you know your sister's
practicing and he went to her house
knocked on the door the person who was
teaching them quran hid
and then they opened the door he busted
in
and he just he knows what's going on he
starts beating on
uh his sister's husband and they start
fighting and then his sister tries to
stop him and
in the heat of a fight you don't really
know what's going on he accidentally
ended up hitting the sister
she comes like from behind to grab him
or something instinctively he turns
around and hits her
she starts bleeding and in in that
entire mess he's like
what the hell am i doing man how did it
get to this point and he's like you know
what give me
what you were reading because i believe
that it was written down he's like let
me read it
and she said okay listen go take a
shower you're dirty go take a shower
come back
and then you could read it i'll let you
touch this pure beautiful words of allah
if you go shower and come back
and he's like okay he goes he showers he
comes back he reads it he gets up
he walks the prophet he walks to where
the muslims are gathered and hums
already
when they're all informed that umar is
on the way hamza the big man
he says if he comes and he has you know
trouble in mind we'll kill him with his
own sword
we will kill him with his own sword this
is how strong this man was even mentally
right and we'll get to the bravery of
the prophet saw i said him in a second
so um comes
and the prophet sees omar this is giant
he walks in
all the muslims are around you know what
should happen is all the muslims kind of
form a line or circle around the prophet
protecting him the prophet salallahu he
runs through his face
he grabs him by his shirt he's like what
brought you here why are you here
and he's like i've come to become a
muslim
and he said
and this is within the like the same
week i believe hamza and um
beautiful stories i love that every time
i listen to it every time i tell it i
love it so much
so now they have these two giants and
they don't have to
before they were practicing in
somebody's home that's where they pray
that was a little measured in somebody's
house
they couldn't the kaaba was right there
but they couldn't pray to it they
couldn't pray
in the kaaba in the haram they couldn't
pray around it because of the
paganism and the people there they tried
once and it did not go
it did not end well they got brutally
messed up unfortunately
but now they have hamza they have omar
dillahu
and they're like we're going to go pray
so we have two lines one
hamza is leading the other omar is
leading they walk right in and they pray
and nobody could stop them not one
person could stop them
huge dub for the muslims alhamdulillah
it's been long so far so i'm going to
wrap up this bit
eventually the uncle of the prophet saw
i saw him dies
and now the uncle of the prophet saw
islam he was giving the prophet
protection
and now the prophet doesn't have
protection and in the same year
the beloved wife of the prophet his
first love
of i believe 15 15 years or no no no
sorry not fifteen i take that back take
that back
but 25 to 40
15. so over 15 years i'll say to be safe
over 15 years she passes away
and it's called the year of sorrow for
the prophet salallahu because he was
such a sad year for him
that allah i believe ended up revealing
surah yusuf which is a beautiful surah
and he ended up giving the prophet the
night journey
where he actually ascended into jannah
and spoke to allah beautiful beautiful
thing
beautiful story masha'allah and on top
of that
later on the prophet saw and the muslims
they got boycotted they ended up leaving
if you want to other places you went the
medini started preaching he sent people
to abyssinia over the years
and eventually after some time
the muslims after being boycotted there
was a caravan i believe
traveling with their belongings because
when you get boycotted you don't get to
pack your suitcases and you know get on
the
get on a nice you know westjet plane and
fly
not like that it's like you're boycotted
you're running away they didn't have
their stuff
so okay of rand was traveling with
herself they want to take their stuff
back
and the meccans the pagans the horrible
people they knew
what was going to happen and they
basically jumped them and they engaged
in the first
battle which is called the battle of
badr the first
battle that the muslims engaged in 313
muslims verse i think
a thousand of these jahils
and the muslims won alhamdulillah they
actually ended up winning by the grace
and the mercy of allah because allah
sent his help
allah sent his help and abu jahl died
and all these
jaahil people died and the muslims
finally got to go back into mecca and
the prophet
when he walked into mecca he went he
stood in front of the people
he's like remember me remember me
remember
i'm joking he didn't take that approach
he went up
he went up and he said people
after everything you put us through what
do you think we're going to do to you
today
after everything you've done what do you
think is gonna happen to you now
after all the torture the persecution
the boycotts what do you think is gonna
happen
and they said you're so merciful you're
gonna let us be
and he said continue with your lives
continue what you're doing
live that was the mercy of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
that was the love that he had in another
instance when he went and preached that
the people were horrible even the like
the
the slaves and the children and the
women and the men everybody was throwing
impure things rocks all this stuff at
him and he started bleeding he went he
sat by a tree
and the angel jibril i believe allah
came down he said listen
these people not great people if you
want
the prophet saws he said if you want i
will take this mountain
i will take this mountain and the cities
in the middle and i will
i will crush them if you want and he
said no don't
perhaps their children will become
muslim one day and then decades later
their children all became muslim all
became muslim alhamdulillah
i just thought that's a little cute
story to add in masha'allah about the
prosthetics
his mercy his his love and his his
planning even
so after some time the prophet saw he's
still revealing
uh he's still being you know given
revelation he's still uh being a prophet
his daily duties all of this guiding the
people and the muslims are getting
bigger and number bigger in number
they have this allegiance this alliance
this peace treaty that peace treaty
they're you know getting big
alhamdulillah and then
i'm going to fast forward there were
battles there were wars huge things i'm
skipping
it's a very like they're very in-depth
masha allah um i encourage everybody to
look it up it is very important it is it
is you know a crucial part of our
history alhamdulillah
and a lot of it has you know is context
for the quran like surah 9 and stuff
surat about repentance talks a lot about
the battles and the wars and stuff
and then afterwards apostles
he gave his last khutbah he gave his
last lecture his last speech the people
and he recited to the people the verse
that allah had revealed
before that saying today i have
perfected your deen and completed my
favor upon you how beautiful how
beautiful allah says i perfected your
religion
and completed my favor to you not your
right
not my obligation i completed a favor
to you that just shows how beautiful
islam
is in the sense that it is a favor a
gift from allah
he a blessing from allah it's beautiful
masha'allah
and at this time two sahabah started
crying
abu bakr allahu and i unfortunately i
forgot the other
of the other name but and he started
crying abu bakr
for two reasons one he knows
once the revelation is done and the
religion is perfect
there is no more need for a prophet
and two he knew that once a religion is
perfect
the only stages after it are
imperfection it can't go up from
perfection it can only go down
and that's why he was very beautiful
they were very wise
and then later on the prosthetic he had
a very bad fever he got sick
and everybody his wives agreed that he
would stay with aisha
because he was in a way closest to her
although he was fair with all his wives
before anybody jumps in and says
anything
he was closest to her
and as he was you know he was passing in
and out of consciousness
going through the trials and
tribulations and the fangs of death
um and had some visitors and all this
and preparing for his final days and
everything
and well a very beautiful story but very
sad
the prophet isam in one of his last you
know words in his
his last bit of life he taught the men
he said
be good to your women be kind to them
right remember your rights to the people
so on and so forth
and the prophetic he would fade in and
out of consciousness and every time he
would fault like he would he would get
up to pray he would pass out he would
wake up and the first thing he would ask
is did the people pray did they pray
and then i would say no they're waiting
for you and he said go tell them to pray
tell them to pray it's okay go and he
gets up and he goes
and he passes out again and then it
happens again he's like tell them to
pray he gets up he goes and he passes
out
i said the first thing he would wake up
thinking about did they pray very
beautiful
and the prophet eventually unfortunately
passed away in the lap of
there are very like in-depth videos on
it so i said i suggest you guys look it
up
it's very touching allah and it's very
sad and then after this the muslims were
kind of in a frenzy
they were freaking out you know the
messenger died
he said if anybody says he's dead i'm
going to cut off your tongue
if anybody comes to me one more time and
says he's dead i'm going to cut off your
tongue
he was so shocked he couldn't even speak
he didn't talk to anybody
everybody was either hidden or freaking
out or they didn't know what was
happening
he goes to the people and he recites the
verses in the quran where allah says
that
the prophet sallallahu alaihi sallam
muhammad al sallallahu islam
is a man he's a messenger he's a man
messengers before him
have passed away or passed on or they're
not here anymore
so if he were to die or be killed
would you then turn back on your heels
would you then go back
and regress very profound
he recites these verses of the people
and they said it's as if we heard it for
the first time
and then they elected abu bakr to be the
first leader after the prophet
salaam and he led and then after him was
um
who spread islam literally all over the
globe
everywhere and islam became the
power it became the
greatest power and one of the longest
lasting
in at least in more recent history
of of the entire world and then after um
it was uthman omar and uthman were both
martyred they were both killed
and taken as sure taken as martyrs and
then
after that was ali radhial and then it
goes on and goes on
very very beautiful that was very very
brief
but you just get a very brief glimpse of
islam
and in all of that the 40 years the
prophet or sorry the 23 years of the
prophet salallahu
being a prophet receiving revelation
very beautiful a hadith that i didn't
talk about very beautiful stories and
narrations i didn't mention
very beautiful times when the quran
would come down
in response to very specific situations
walla it is so deep
and it is so beautiful
guys fellows any of you guys are
watching this
may allah make us even one millionth of
the man
that the rasulullah messenger of allah
was
do you know what the prophet said as his
last words
in his deathbed yay
i don't know bro that's not what he said
what he said was
salah
and what your right hand possesses
those were his last words salah means
prayer so
he said salah three times and
what your right hand possesses those
that look up to you those that are
under you those that you must lead
well i think i think it's beautiful um
how rami said that last bit
where he was like that a lot basically
said
um today i complete my favor
on to you and well like to me that's
beautiful because
i've looked into multiple religions
throughout the many years that i've been
on this
spiritual path trying to find the truth
and brothers like you find bits and
pieces
in so many places but it's like islam
has everything this is the complete
puzzle and then for you to say that
where it's like allah says like today i
complete my
favor on to you that's like look like
the message has finally
been transmitted we no longer have to
keep going we no longer have to play
this telephone game
and that's beautiful man
yo so i do have a question though
yeah do you
do you know anymore about hamza
do i know any more about about
hamza or illinois and i was also going
to ask after you're done addressing his
question
wasn't it omar um peace be upon him that
it took him six years to accept islam it
was both of them hamza and
they converted like in the same few days
even
six years man yeah it took it took the
second
who's deemed you know four of the
rightly guided leaders
somebody who's guaranteed paradise
guaranteed
somebody who was told and this authentic
is debated whether it's all you know
this sorry hadith is this narrations
debated whether it's authentic or not
but he was told if there was going to be
a prophet after me it would be
there isn't but if there was it would be
omar this man and this man who was told
that if shaitaan sees you walking down a
path he goes the other way
he doesn't even waste his time on you
this man took six years six years to
accept islam
and we have people today we have people
today
that won't even pick up the quran
because they don't think they're good
enough they won't even pray because they
don't think they're good enough because
they've been
astray for a little bit because they
made one mistake this man was
jahil for this entire time and islam
came to him for six years and he didn't
accept it he persecuted muslims as well
i don't know if you could say
persecuting muslims but he was amongst
the people who did
and he was going to kill the prophet
salallahu he's literally about to like
that's the lowest of the low killing the
messenger that's the lowest of the low
and he became someone who's guaranteed
paradise
and now on hamza
i don't know too too much about him
obviously he was a great warrior he was
a great fighter
he was the uncle of prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam um
i could talk about the battle in which
he died in sha allah but he was also
called the lion of allah
i believe he was called the lion of
allah because
of how fierce he was especially in
battle
so the battle of
i believe is the battle of was one of
the worst battles
led by somebody who eventually became
muslim but he was an amazing
strategist when it comes to any military
endeavors any battles any wars and he
fights
he was brilliant so he he basically
came up with this strategy which the
prophet salallahu actually he
counteracted this strategy
before it even started but the the
people the archers of the prophet said
and put on a hill
he told them don't come down no matter
what if the muslims are dying don't come
down
if we're collecting collecting loot and
gold and treasure in the booty of war
don't come down they disobeyed him some
of them tried to stay but most of them
disobeyed
and then the line of defense was broke
and
the khadid ibn walid who was the man who
who led the other um army
around the mountain to basically trap
the muslims and in this
must passed away who actually said the
famous verses that muhammad
he said it during this battle he said
muhammad is a man
he's a messenger messengers before him
have passed away
if he were to die or be slain are you
going to go back in your heels and that
stuff and then allah
put that in the quran for those of you
don't know
very beautiful and in this battle hamza
as well um i don't remember the the
story fully so i don't want to
misconstrue it um but i believe there
was this one
person on the other side who you who was
really good at spear throwing and
basically he kept trying to get um uh
sorry he kept trying to get hamza and
hamza no noticed it he knew it
ready he kept trying again he kept
trying to get him uh i think he
he like he snuck up behind him or
something or he finally got the time the
right
spot and he threw the spear and it hit
hamza
and for a while he was still standing i
think he was actually walking towards
the person
and the person was scared like damn i'm
gonna die now
right i stepped up to the big cat like
it's done now
but then unfortunately he passed away he
did not survive that
[Music]
very unfortunate that was very very sad
and hard for the prophet
he lost man the prophet saw islam
for the kind man he was and for how much
he cared about everybody he lost
so much man he had most of his kids
passed away
he went through so much grief and the
the trial the test of being a prophet
is the hardest thing in the world a
messenger that is the hardest mission in
the world
and on top of that and this is why it's
one of the hardest missions because he
lost his followers he lost his children
part of me he lost
and the uncle in the same year he was
boycotted he was kicked out he was
persecuted he went through
so much so much as a prophet salallahu
as a messenger and despite all that he
was still so empathetic
he was still so kind hearted he still
taught islamically one of the greatest
principles even in like the court of law
which is innocent until proven guilty
where do you think this came from the
muslims started it
as far as i know the muslims started it
and it came from islam
the fact that if someone comes to you
you know about you saying he did this
that
they need evidence and you are innocent
until they prove you did something wrong
and if not then they get they get lashed
for slander
or defamation as you might call it very
beautiful
and he brought all these amazing things
he pushed people
um and the quran and islam pushed people
inspired people
to start in
in science in mathematics to invest
invent uh algebra which comes from the
term algebra which basically means the
one who like
puts things together which is basically
what algebra is it's finding
what's broken fixing it something like
that and
i mean i know what algebra is but in
terms of the definition of algebra
and math uh sorry um
algorithms and all of that science the
scientific method
and the enhancements of science which
some people say if the muslims didn't do
that we would be 300 years
back in terms of our technological
advancements all these things
all these things and the morality and
the principles
of islam which actually strike many of
the you know the world's most
recognizable people today
um who fell in love with the quran or
fell in love with islam
or the prophet even gandhi wrote about
him very beautiful words gandhi wrote
about him
if any of you interested you should look
it up um well
so many things there's so many things to
talk about man i need i need a sense of
direction with this because
good thing we have a whole podcast bro
that is true
so i guess it's a good time to talk
about i'm talking about the fossils and
being such a good person i should give
some examples
so just to give one example of his
empathy
we talked about abu jahl and how
horrible of a person he was right
the father of jesus
this man one of the worst enemies of
islam
after he passed away his son was going
to visit the muslims
right imagine your enemy's son is coming
to see you
right like imagine hitler's son was
going to come visit us
we're going to be like what the hell
what's up with this guy we're not gonna
be super nice to him
but do you know what the prophet
salallahu said he told his companions
when he comes here when his son gets
here nobody call his father abu jahl
call him umar ibn hisham call him by
because if he comes and he sees we're
calling him abu jahl and he's just died
that's gonna hurt that's gonna hit him
man don't do that
just take in his emotional intelligence
we'll get to that
we will get to that is a big topic and
the prophet sam was the most emotionally
intelligent person
subhanallah so
he says even if his son were to become
muslim
and know what his father did was wrong
it would still hurt him and then
he took off his shirt and he put it on
abu jahen
and he they buried him in that as a sign
of you know
respect at least to the son for the son
think about how kind the prosthetic was
especially in that instance this is the
man who tortured him and persecuted him
and his followers
just for believing in allah just for
believing there's one god worthy of
worship
persecuted murdered boycotted
and that much love from the prophet
salaam
it's insane it's insane how many people
today would do something like that
into that that's selfless that's
selfless
that's selfless dude subhanallah
sallallahu amazing character man amazing
character i also heard this one story
that there was he had a jewish and
elderly jewish neighbor
who used to always like throw trash and
garbage and rubbish at him every time he
left his house
and one day the prophet i sent him he
noticed that they didn't one day they
just didn't throw anything at him
and they weren't there ready to throw
things i mean most of us would be like
thank god right like what's up this guy
throwing
or this guy it's disputed whether it's a
lady or a man i've always heard it's an
elderly lady for the sake of it we'll go
with that it's always like what's wrong
with this lady man this old hat why is
she throwing things at me that's what we
would say
but the prophet saw i sent him the one
day the one day he saw that she's not
throwing trash at him
and she's nowhere to be found to throw
trash at him he made to go see if she's
okay
he made to go make sure that she's okay
and when he went inside she was passing
away she was
on her deathbed and she was she wasn't
she didn't have anybody by her side so
the prosthetic was the only person that
stayed with her while she passed away
think about how beautiful that is man
how many people today would be happy and
say good riddance she's dead
faster that i sent him he sat by her
side while she was passing away
and this is our role model if you can't
take this as a role model
there is something wrong with you i'm
sorry you do have issues
perhaps you do need a psychiatric
evaluation
no but men and women alike everyone can
benefit from looking at the prophet
as a role model
i mean credit where credit is due he was
the best man that's why he's called a
mercy to all of mankind
to all of creation because he wouldn't
even be an animal
he wouldn't even be an animal sallallahu
this is the character that he had
this is the love and the empathy and and
the care that he had
at the same time he was firm he was
unmoved
and he was very strict on the deen where
it matters his morals right like a real
man should like a good man should
he wasn't a nice guy that said okay i'll
let this go i'll let that go if
something is firm it is firm
islamically that's it like when the
pagan said okay we'll accept
islam just let us keep our idols we
won't worship them
but let us keep them he said nope nope
and they said okay
at least let us keep it for like a week
or something he said nope they said okay
at least today he's like nope
he's like okay at least don't make us
the ones who destroy them he's okay i'll
send people to
to get rid of them and then he sent
people
to destroy the the idols
so he was the perfect balance and this
is what i think i was talking about in
the last episode
we recorded where some people hear these
nice stories about the process and they
think that's all it is
that's not all it is or they hear one
story about war and they think that's
all it is that's not all it is
there are both sides to it he had the
balance
he was the most emotionally intelligent
man
like it's it's if there's anything if
there is anything anybody should study
or if there's any person that you should
study
it is the prophet salallahu let's just
say we had the perfect man
who did everything i won't say perfect
in the sense that like
no mistakes were made because no human
is perfect that is an inherent trait of
any
human being that they are not perfect
but to the highest degree to the highest
level to the highest standard possible
set by allah subhanahu wa this man to be
the example for all the mankind if we
had that
would you not want to study it if he was
alive today would you not want to follow
him everywhere he went
there even some sahaba that tried to
peek and see how he used the bathroom
and you may be laughing at it now but
let's be honest if he was the perfect
man
you would want to be there for
everything and obviously not everything
everything but
you would want to see how he does
everything because he lived the best
lifestyle to him because he was the best
of creation
and if you can't take that as a role
model or an inspiration to be better at
least
and ladies and gentlemen let me tell you
this is what inspired me
as a young man 16 17 year old this is
what inspired me this was my role model
the best of men and now none of us are
ever going to be anywhere close to him
ever but he's the best and this is
someone we should at least look up to
it's not an excuse
knowing you're never going to be there
you can't you only fail if you give up
so just try
learn about the faucets and every time
you learn something new
implement it into your life and that is
how you grow
dude i would go as far as to say that
like when people
are saying stuff about the prophet peace
be upon him
they're just envious the envy is because
dude like that that was like everything
you just described
is the description of a perfect human
being
and it's like bro if if someone is
perfect
you envy them and envy is a form of love
it's just
hate and love at the same time facts
damn so it's like bro of course they're
gonna say something because like
a part of them wants to be like that but
it's like a part of them doesn't want to
accept that ah this person was like a
perfect human being
so let me actually put him down let me
bring him down to like
uh my level or not even my level at some
level that they perceive as being lower
than what they are at
yeah subhan allah the more perfect that
there is someone at hand that
is a fascinating study the more apparent
our innate flaws become
and to compensate we just start lashing
them bashing them
not really glorifying them as much as
they should be
yeah and that's exactly why when france
and
china and a lot of people oppress
muslims and they speak against the
prophet
bro what do you expect like we're just
gonna like allow it of course yeah we're
not gonna we're not gonna
i don't condone any of the acts that
have happened there was some serious
heinous acts but
at the same time like there's no basis
to why they're attacking the prophet
and defaming him and yeah drawing
cartoons of him
yeah but as we always say man the truth
has enemies at the end of the day
the truth has enemies and you know
what's amazing you know the most
poetic part about it is that they hate
him so much
but they cannot stop talking about him
they can't stop talking about him if you
hate him so much just
ignore him walk away i told you bro envy
yeah he's in love at the same time
the obsession was it you that told me
about uh
that was drake it was drake that said
that
wait what
first of all i was talking about your
child not even you
and second knock do not call me a jail
jacket what i was telling what i was
telling uh rami was was it you that was
telling me about the ex-muslims
and how ex-muslims are the ones that
talk about islam the most
even though that it's something they're
trying to leave but they'll be talking
about
it's actually amazing because if you
look at like 9 11
and afterwards the conversion rate of
muslims spiked
yo the amount of reverse after 9 11 was
insane
yeah subhan allah it's well it's like
it's just
man actually i'm gonna tell the story
because i think it's funny i had this
old uh manager when i worked at
superstore
and i left before he left but i came
back one day
to you know to go and talk some people
that still work there and the the
current manager told me a story that
you know when this is right before kobit
started right uh
he was gonna i think he was gonna quit
and then they ended up firing him or
they were gonna fire him and ended up
quitting something like that
just they weren't on good terms he got
so mad
he went and he ordered a bunch of milk
that he knew they couldn't handle they
would overstock it would go expired
they'd have a big problem
he did that on purpose to bother them to
throw them off
but then kovit hit and then everybody
ran at the stores trying to stock up on
everything
and they actually didn't end up having
enough milk
after he ordered way too much it didn't
have enough milk to give out
and to sell to people so it just kind of
threw it back in his face
and that's basically the life of an
ex-muslim who's trying to
hate on islam you come and you talk all
this you know nonsense and then people
look into islam and they're like oh
that's not what you're what you're
saying what it says here in the quran
actually it doesn't match up as a normal
human being would read it and see that
it's not it's not adding up so they
would be like you're the liar
and they'd be like whoa this is actually
true and then they accept the saddam
bro beautiful bro i was talking to fired
about this last night
but i feel strongly that people who
are ex-muslim and who am i
right who am i to say this because i'm a
reaver and i'm still new to this
but i feel very strongly that people who
are ex-muslim
they are so because
they listen to the whispers and you know
you already know
who was who was saying those whispers
bro i don't have to say it
everyone was watching they already knows
you guys want to say go ahead say bro
but they listened to those whispers and
that led them
off the straight path bro and i'm i was
telling
fire bro we we live in the dunya
right we live in the dunya and bro
people will even go as far as to say
that the dunya
is like a matrix you ever seen the movie
the matrix
where it's like what he was experiencing
wasn't exactly it
there was something else and i'm not
saying that okay that's what's actually
going on but what i am saying is that
the dunya is
very very similar to what that is it's
like a matrix it's like a stimulations
it's something that's happening right
now and if you notice
in the movie the matrix there were
glitches in the matrix that like
he started seeing like oh like this
isn't it or something like that bro
i remember i woke up it was um
it was a normal dipper but i felt
amazing you know when you feel good and
you you tell yourself like damn like
today's gonna be a good day
like it ends up being a pretty damn good
day
for the most part right but as i said
that
a negative thought started coming in and
if i would have entertained that
that would have brought my day all the
way down here didn't entertain it kept
going
bro then my mom came at me she started
telling me something that was like
happening her
like just drama bro and i was like bro i
was just sitting back just kind of like
paying attention just like
listening to everything and then bro my
mom came at me again and she started
saying something and then i looked on
youtube and i started seeing all the
hate messages
from people about me going into islam
and then i went on twitter and then i
had this guy
who's an ex-muslim and he was saying
something
and i was like hmm let me actually
respond because i feel like i do have
something to say here
on this specific topic that him and i'm
talking about
i'm not even putting him down but like
what he was saying
was getting pretty negative and like
everything that was happening around me
everything that i was like
reading everything that um this guy was
saying as well
was starting to bring me down from like
what i was feeling i went from feeling
really good
so now it's like man i don't i don't
really feel too good i actually feel
like kind of troubled like kind of
in this ease if you know what i mean and
bro
bro i kid you not bro as i'm typing a
response to this guy
i'm putting in this word and my phone
literally
auto corrects the word to devil
bro and as soon as they corrected that
bro i just put my phone like i just
pulled my phone away and i looked around
i was like
oh bro i had broke goosebumps just going
through my body bro that was a glitch
in the dunya bro in the matrix
i don't know bro i caught you slipping
crazy
it's crazy bro the prophet he said that
i will guarantee jannah i will guarantee
paradise
for the one who gives up arguing even if
he is correct
even if he's right because because
shaitaan he
loves he loves for you know this drama
and these problems in this nation
because they break people down they ruin
people and when you're in a fight what
happens you start yelling
you scream you get vulgar you start
insulting you start and now
you're being sinful as well so of course
shaytaan's gonna love that
you did the the right thing may allah
bless you alhamdulillah and
that's who it is shaytaan on the point
of ex-muslims a lot of them leave
because
okay i'm gonna say this once and only
once because it should be clear enough
ex-muslims are only ex-muslims
because of emotional reasons they are
never
ex-muslims and i'm not saying this with
any disrespect to them
with all due respect they're only
ex-muslims because of emotional
reasons because of emotional arguments
you will never have an
anybody forget ex-muslims you'll never
have anybody come with one logical
reason
or one rational really a reason why
somebody should not believe in the
religion of islam
as a whole you will not find one logical
irrational reason
it's always why why is this the moral
standing why is this allowed and this
isn't
i don't like that oh okay
and i don't like that you don't like
that
does like that does that make a
difference at the end of the day no
because the truth hurts man
reality doesn't always fit our our likes
and our wants and our whims
it doesn't always fit our desires but
it's true nonetheless man
i went through a very bad time very bad
time am i to look at it and say it
didn't happen it wasn't real
because i don't like it it's not the
truth no it's the truth man and it hurts
but that doesn't mean that you shouldn't
believe in it if it's true logically
rationally
there's no reason not believing it it
supersedes anything else
then why shouldn't you believe in it
it's the most logical rational decision
you can make
but every single time it's emotional
emotional arguments and well
what's so funny i'm gonna reiterate this
point because it's so
poetic you have people who hate islam so
much yet
their income their lifestyle their their
status online
everything they have is because of
hating on islam
we have people with patrons i get
thousands of dollars a month to lie
about islam
to be soy boys on the internet and lie
about islam
to be jahils on online about islam
exactly just to lie about islam and they
hate islam so much but their life
is basically dedicated to it
well that's poetic man
but it's like that verse says man it's
like sometimes you might like something
it's not good for you and then sometimes
you might not like something
but it is good for you yeah and guys
that's that's the red pill
when you take the red pill you're waking
up
and it does suck man like i'll be honest
with you
do i like hypergamy no
that doesn't mean i don't i don't see it
for what it is that doesn't mean that i
write it off as being
uh some made-up thing that it's not real
because bro like i experienced it
firsthand
i saw my friends i saw my family members
getting done 30 by hypergamy bro my
uncle came from texas and i'm going to
leave out names because if i say names
it might cause some issues right but he
came from texas
he actually brought this woman that he
was uh
in love with she had a son he fell in
love with her
bro he brought her through the border
through the border of texas of like
mexico to texas where it's like they
have
bro helicopters people with guns like
the army and everything where it's like
they're trying to catch people
that are trying to go the immigrants
that are trying to cross the border bro
he went through all of that where he
risked his life
he risked his freedom for this woman bro
and then the moment he got into america
with her
bro guess what she did yep
yeah left them left and bro
so again do i like hypergamy no
i don't like it i don't agree with it
but it is what it is yeah
man man i feel for a man all i feel for
him
this is why we need the day of judgment
because this life is not fair let's say
one man kills a hundred people
you can only kill him once you can't
kill him a hundred times
but allah can if he wants
so like man you're not gonna have
justice in this world so if you believe
that things should be just and unfair
that's what the day of judgment is
that's what allah promises every wrong
will be made right
no stone will be left unturned
everything is known
everything will be recompensed whether
it's in your favor or against you
yo so this is a side note but i want to
know what y'all feel about this
all right because when rami was saying
his uh
his part he was saying the story of the
prophet peace be upon him
hamza and omar you know how like when we
were kids
we would either watch like a movie or a
tv show or we would listen to a story
and like we would listen to the
characters and we'd be like ah
i could see myself as this character
like i don't know about y'all but i have
a feeling that like no one in this world
can listen to the story of the prophet
peace be upon him and say like i could
be this character
because he he's he's just such a perfect
being
even in the stories but he's like bro
you said hamza
and like as you're describing him like
ah i could see myself
as this dude because i like fighting i
like mma i like
str strut strategy bro strategy i love
strategy man like i
i live for that stuff but it's like it's
crazy because like you
you were saying everything about the
prophet and it's like
to me i couldn't even rationalize in my
head like ah yeah i could see myself as
this guy i could strive for that
but i just i can't see myself like that
because that's that's perfection
wallahi bro i never thought about it
like that to be honest subhanallah
that's true dang man
because the process i sent him he was
like he was just balanced he was
perfectly balanced
not everybody was but he was so loyal to
them so
i thought man jeez
right it's like it's the best podcast
yet
and then we have another one yeah yeah i
i know i know
but that's how it is but that's how it
is when real recognized real
yeah this is like this is i said i was
gonna prepare but i didn't prepare
anything i was sitting on my bed
i like i wasn't thinking i got on like
no way yeah
is that is that [ __ ] behind you your bed
no but it's behind my bed's behind the
sheet
many of y'all that are wondering what
he's going on about 30 minutes before a
call
maybe 45 minutes or an hour he asked me
what this topic was
about today's podcast 30 minutes before
that
angel hit us up and asked do we even
want to record tonight we weren't even
planning on recording any podcast
tonight
and it just came to me i was like why
don't we talk about the history of islam
five minutes later he sends me an
imessage of a screenshot
tell him what the screenshot was it was
of my friend kevin
saint kevin on ig shout out to him he's
a great guy he's a christian guy and
he's like you know what rami
i'm curious about the history of islam
can you show me or tell me about the
history of islam maybe she sent me some
videos and i'm like
what the hell i got you i'm like man
kevin i'm recording a podcast about this
right now i'll send you when it's
released
yeah i didn't know the topic so five
minutes before
yeah i mean it's meant to be this way
right it's meant to be unscripted
alhamdulillah so yeah everything was off
the top
this i'm gonna say this now because it's
really important when it comes to things
like
being like let's just say that academics
right you need
scholarly sources you need proper
sources you need proper
um just understanding storytelling
whatever it is right you need the proper
methods the proper scholarly methods of
proper delivery
and to make sure that information is all
authentic alhamdulillah i know
everything i said was authentic
alhamdulillah i learned it
um with my the the young diver course
that i've been taking
so i know something alhamdulillah but
everything i said was just off the top
based on what i memorized and if you
were amazed with that imagine how much
more there is man it's not limited to
this it's limited to
what's out there so i suggest everybody
go look up the life of the prophet
the sahaba the history of islam the
first revelation the last revelation
everything in between
and everything afterwards look it up
because
it is so fascinating and there is
like if if i were to study one thing for
the rest of my life without a doubt
it would be islam without a doubt it
would be the left apostles
islam as a whole for the rest of my life
i don't care if i'm a bum
because that is the most
just red pill alpha kind of information
any man woman child could take in life
and if you have that
you just to summarize it if you run
if you if you if you chase the dunya if
you chase the world it's going to run
away from you
but if you chase the achira if you chase
the hair after the dunya will be at your
feet and with studying islam you're
chasing the afterlife and one thing i
wanted to mention actually on hell
because you talked about it
i was at work and i was talking to my
friend muhammad and i was like
man sometimes i've just forget about
jannah i forget it exists
i'm so focused on what i'm doing here
right now
and i keep forgetting that you know
we're just trying to get to jannah we're
not even meant to be here
we have responsibilities yeah we have
tasks but we're not meant to be here
forever i'm like
i forget about that and that's when
depression hits me when i when i forget
that when i die everything my problems
die with me whatever
and then there's there's a hereafter and
allah grants us
but um i mean i feel like so many people
forget about jannah especially
in the altercations and the fights and
the stress and the anxiety and the
depression they forget
they forget about tenna and everybody
anybody who's watching this
if jannah exists if you're a muslim you
believe in jannah it exists
what are you doing to get there what
are you doing to get there
let's say you just bought a house go on
you're on it you're on it right now keep
going let's say you just bought a house
it's down the street it's one month go
by two months go by
an entire life time goes by and you
never even moved in there
anybody any normal person would ask
listen your house is right here
you just bought this home why did you
not do anything to
you know to get there move your stuff
pack up get ready hire a company
something do something to get there
what you expected you're going to be
picked up like you know happy bee
for you ship you to your house no man so
what are you doing to achieve the
greatest
the greatest kind of reward from allah a
house in jannah house in paradise for
eternity forever
what are you doing to achieve that
if you have a problem believing in it
then dm me or go back to our first
episode
where we talk about proof that allah
exists and
and then proof that islam is true and so
on and so forth
and then ask yourself again what are you
doing to get to jannah
and if you forget about it then that's
an issue because that is your one
priority imagine the most important
thing in life the most important thing
in life
and you're not thinking about it you're
thinking about the small minor problems
you have
when the main goal is right there in
front of your eyes the whole time and
you've been neglecting it man if that's
not pathetic
i don't know what is dude i was gonna
say like
i had someone message me uh
a spoken word i know what those things
are
yeah yeah there's um i think it's uh
it's one of those really popular islamic
channels the
the dude that made all the beasts the
the meaning of life
the islamic spoken word or something
like bro
mastermind mastermind but he made this
video and this guy sent it to me where
it's like it literally says exactly what
you did or what you're saying
whereas like once that day comes like
what have you done for this day
like let's say you spent your entire
life you didn't do your prayers
you said no no i'll do my prayers later
on once like the timing is perfect
or it's like you didn't you didn't do
sakai you didn't do charity
it's like oh i needed to pay bills and
stuff like that
it's like bro it's just excuses you just
kept putting things off but then it's
like
you promised death if there's one thing
in this life that you are promised
whether you're a believer or a
non-believer
is death man i'm gonna tie this back to
that story you told because wildlife is
amazing
so remember the story you mentioned
about your uncle who went and into
mexico
fell in love and brought the the woman
over to
right man think about the border as
being death
think about america being the afterlife
think about mexico being this current
life
and think about the woman as being the
worldly desires
you build up so much you work so hard
for the worldly desires
and you expect that what is going to
come to the grave with you as soon as
you pass through the border of life and
you die
the woman everything your wealth
everything it leaves you
it runs away from you and what are you
left with once you're on the other side
nothing except regret and disappointment
you don't want to be like that we don't
want to be like that that's why we're
here man
and that's why you're here with us so go
pray man
go give two and a half percent of what
you earn in charity two and a half
if you were poor you would want at least
that you would want half of that you you
would want anything you can get
go take care of the orphans man go try
and be like the best
be like the prophet absolutely
man excel in this life excel
bro so you know how you're talking about
like
just all the stories of the prophet
peace be upon him i don't know how to
say that other part yet i gotta
practice but um
i think it's amazing that what you said
was just like
this much and that there's so much out
there that you can
research and you can find yourself bro
cause i remember when i was actually
looking into christianity when i was
with my ex bro like i remember
being in her living room and like i had
heard something
the previous day at church when we went
and they were talking about um i forgot
the name of it but there's this brief
period in time where like
jesus is just like absent he like he
goes off and he does something
and then he comes back and when he comes
back that's supposedly when he's like
he's now the son of god
he's now awakened and he's like doing
the miracles and stuff like that
and it's like i want to know what
happened during that time
so bro i was in that living room just
like looking as through the tv because
they had like an anomaly tv so i was
looking just trying to find answers
trying to find
anything any documentation any
legitimate sources
of what happened during that time frame
and if i could figure out what the name
is
after the fact after this podcast i'll
definitely link it
but man i was trying to find that i
remember her mom
came down and she asked me what i was
doing and i told her
and she's like oh that's that's stupid
why would you even need to know that i'm
like
what how is that stupid like that gives
you insight into
the quote-unquote son of god his life
and like what he was doing and like how
he came to be what he
is so it's like how is that not
important and then bro here you have in
islam you have the documentation
of the prophet's life peace be upon him
bro so it lets you see
what he went through his trials his
tribulations how he
how he he was actually testing how he
grew
and it's like that bro that's priceless
that's what i was looking for in
christianity
and here it is in islam bro and allah
man what are your thoughts
it's 11 30. let's cut it off you know
what that means
yeah it was a great podcast y'all i'm
not
man it was real alhamdulillah
close it out boy take it away bro
all right hold on let me say one last
thing let me say one last thing
if you made it this far comment down
below
that fire is a jahil
so we know it's real
user all right
and with that being said
has
foreign